We human can easily tell the difference
between happy and sad songs,
but can this be captured in an algorithm?
Starting with guitar chords and 10,000 emotional words
ranked by paid online workers,
researchers analyzed which chords were paired
with positive and negative emotions in lyrics
in tens of thousands of popular songs.
As expected, minor chords were linked with sad words
and major chords with happy ones
BUT the most positive emotions
were conveyed by seventh chords.
Seventh chords start out like any other chord,
with a triad of notes, however,
7ths add an extra note on top
that changes the sound.
There are both major and minor sevenths,
depending on the pitch of that extra note,
and both are prevalent in happier songs.
If you tell this result to a musician,
there may be some head scratching--
there’s irony in songs--
pairing of emotions and sounds that mesh or jar--
depending on the intentions of the creator.
Also, sevenths are very much the domain of jazz --
extra complexity that adds color
and texture to many songs without words.
But, these pairings did happen in these data
--this set of songs
more 7ths than expected--paired with happy lyrics.
With this new take on musical happiness in mind,
we’ll play our selves out, with a very happy tune..
according to this study.